So, we certainly did have a great year at Google...
...and I'd really like to think some of it stems from the unique way that we manage our product and engineering machine.
When we hire product managers, they often come in and they ask me, they say,...
..."So, how do we measure success at Google?"
And I always tell them, "It's simple"...
..."At the end of the year, we make a list of all of your successes and your failures."...
..."You're then measured on the sum of your successes"...
..."and by how much you learned from your failures".
So, at the beginning of 2010,...
...one of our concerns was that as we scaled, this approach might lead to our being spread too thin.
Instead, we thought, "Maybe we needed to put more wood behind fewer arrows".
So, we made some changes.
And I think they addressed this concern...
...without actually affecting the basic philosophy of how we've always run product and engineering at Google.
So, let's talk about what we changed.
At the beginning of the year, we decided to double down on the core...
...so that's search and search ads,...
...and I think the financial numbers that you guys are seeing today,...
...reflect the fact that that was a successful bet.
But behind those numbers...
...is a really relentless stream of new features and product innovations.